if we look at at mariupol clearly um the
the
number of deaths of civilian casualties
there is is significantly higher we are
trying to look into the scale um
we have for example got increasing
information on on mass grades that are
there uh for example one mass grave
we've been able to get satellite
information on and we estimate that one
of those mass graves holds about 200
people
day after day the death toll and human
suffering in cities towns and villages
across ukraine is increasing
the facts as we've been recording them
speak for themselves
since russian armed forces launched
their attacks on the 24th of february at
least
1035 civilians have been killed and at
least 1
650 injured
i say at least because we do not yet
have the full picture of locations that
have seen intense fighting in particular
in mariupol and valle baja
in terms of enforced disappearances we
have as i mentioned we've documented 22
uh enforced disappearances or arbitrary
arrests of
of local officials again this does seem
to be a pattern that is occurring in
areas that are occupied
by the russian federation that armed
forces of the russian federation are
going specifically to detain or and do
not
inform relatives and others where they
are taking people
and that does in some cases appear to be
a form of hostage taking
the extent of civilian casualties and
the destruction of civilian objects
strongly suggests that the principles of
distinction of proportionality the rule
on feasible precautions and the
prohibition of indiscriminate attacks
have been violated